[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory in
today's video we're going to be
discussing hogwarts school its founders
the sorting system and most closely the
sorting hat
as we know hogwarts school was founded
when four 10th century witches and
wizards realized that they had the same
yearning to create the world's best
magic school
their names were godric gryffindor
salazar sutherin helga hufflepuff and
rowena ravenclaw once these four
powerful witches and wizards had created
the school they decided that they would
create some kind of system for dividing
the school students
thus the house system was born this was
because despite very much being on the
same page in terms of building a school
the founders were also wise enough to
realize that they were very different
people who valued very different things
this meant that dividing their teaching
ideologies was of utmost importance
gryffindor students embodied bravery and
chivalry ravenclaw intelligence and wit
hufflepuff loyalty and fair play and
slytherin the values of being sly and
cunning after these houses were
established the hogwarts founders served
as head of these houses for many years
sorting students into their houses
manually however when it occurred to
them that they wouldn't be around
forever they needed to come up with some
sort of a way that they could continue
to sort students when they were no
longer around
thus the sorting hat was born
godric gryffindor pulled his completely
normal hat off of his head and made the
suggestion to the other founders that
using their collective magic they
enchant the hat and turn it into a
sentient being it was important to the
founders that the houses they formed
would continue to follow by the beliefs
from which they were based these virtues
or inherent characteristics are best
summed up in the sorting hats own words
by gryffindor the bravest were prized
far beyond the rest for ravenclaw the
cleverest would always be the best for
hufflepuff hard workers were most worthy
of admission and power hungry slytherin
loved those of great ambition after
placing the sorting hat on your head the
hat analyzes your mind using legitimacy
and places you in a house based on how
closely you resemble one of the four
founders if the hat senses great bravery
gryffindor is a likely choice if the hat
senses great intelligence ravenclaw is a
likely choice if the hat senses that
someone is a hard worker hufflepuff is a
likely choice and finally if the hat
senses that someone is hungry for power
then slytherin is a likely choice
however there are of course other
factors that come into play when
determining a student's house this one
primary characteristic isn't all there
is to it the hat made things much easier
for the four founders and it couldn't
have come at a better time as they were
beginning to have a bit of a falling out
the 10th century was a tough time for
witches and wizards as they were subject
to all sorts of persecution from muggles
in the forms of witch hunts etc and so
salazar slytherin who vehemently hated
muggles for what they had done to his
kind proclaimed that he would never
accommodate muggleborn students at his
school the other founders didn't share
the same belief and eventually things
hit a tipping point with slytherin
leaving the school all together
in the end gryffindor along with the
other founding members of hogwarts
decided that enough was enough and
slytherin left the school
however what i want to highlight today
is that the sorting hat had more than
just one purpose it wasn't just a means
of sorting students it also had another
function you see godric gryffindor laid
another secret enchantment on the hat
and it had to do with this sword
sometime just before or sometime during
his time at hogwarts godric gryffindor
had commissioned the creation of a
silver sword in later years it would
become known simply as the sword of
gryffindor but during that time the
goblins who had created the blade might
have known it as ragnarok's sword after
all ragnarok the first one of the
greatest silversmiths of the age had
spread a rumor amongst the goblin
community that the sword was actually
his and gryffindor had stolen it the
goblins had been so angered by the news
that a group of easily manipulated
goblin thugs tried to knock godric
unconscious and rip the sword from him
gryffindor famously withdrew his wand in
response and cast a spell on the
woefully outmatched goblins sending them
back to ragnarok for the threat of their
own if the goblin ever tried to steal
the sword again godric would drag its
blade through the lot of them and leave
them lifeless on their dust-covered
foundry floor when gryffindor joined the
other three founders in enchanting the
sorting hat he also added an additional
bit of magic whenever a true gryffindor
was in need of help they could reach
their hand into the hat to withdraw
ragnarok's sword in may of 1993 we see
harry potter reach into the sorting hat
and pull the sword when his and ginny
weasley's lives were in danger as a
result of salazar slytherin's basilisk
oh yeah i didn't mention the basilisk
yet before leaving the school for good
salazar southern wanted to leave a
lasting impression and so he built a
secret chamber within the school that
housed a giant basilisk intended to rid
the school of any non-pure bloods we
know that harry eventually uses the
sword to kill the basilisk so what we
can infer here is that godric gryffindor
knew about the chamber and wanted to put
some sort of defense in the hands of his
future students alternatively godric
gryffindor simply put the powerful
weapon there for general use as he was a
combat obsessed wizard from the dark
ages whatever the reason gryffindor had
the best intentions in mind hoping to
help future generations of students that
came from his house but my question is
what about the other houses what would
happen if a true and worthy hufflepuff
ravenclaw or slytherin reached into the
sorting hat during their time of need
would anything appear i've got a few
theories
all of them enchanted the hats after all
okay so first of all let me address why
i think it's plausible that the other
founders would have also stored a hidden
item only revealed by the hat
yes the hat was godric's but that
doesn't mean that he would have excluded
the other founders from utilizing it in
a similar way if he did indeed store the
sword there to protect his future
students from salazarian's basilisk and
he was fully aware of the basilisk why
would godric being the good and brave
man he was leave hufflepuff and
ravenclaw students defenseless why
wouldn't he allow helga hufflepuff and
rowena ravenclaw to store similar
artifacts in the hats
if we go by this logic then that would
of course mean that southern students
would be the only ones to not pull
anything from the hat as the core
purpose of storing these items inside of
the hat was to combat salazar
so what would helga and rowena pull out
of it if we look at the significance of
godric gryffindor's sword we know from
canon that it was a possession of
particular importance to him it makes
perfect sense that godric a fighter
would place a sword there that could
fight off a basilisk an item that one
could use to defend themselves so what
items were similarly important to helga
and rowena
well if you're any sort of harry potter
fan at all then you'll know that two
defining items associated with these
witches were helga hufflepuff's cup and
rowena ravenclaw's diadem however these
can't have been the items drawn from the
hat for a few reasons
first of all both of them were turned
into horcruxes and their prior locations
were known second of all these items
would not have been practical at all in
a fighting scenario
so what did they leave well i'm of the
impression that both witches left their
ones in the hat if we go by canon we
don't know much about the details
pertaining to the ones of these witches
what they were made of or where they are
but we do know that they were likely
powerful magical instruments as they
were suited to some of the most powerful
witches to have ever existed i know what
you're thinking now aren't ones
extremely personalized what about one
law what about the one's allegiance why
would the ones of such powerful witches
work for young students well that comes
back to the function of the hat for a
gryffindor student to pull the sword of
gryffindor from the hat they have to be
a true worthy gryffindor we also know
from one law that if a wand which is a
quasi-sentient item deem someone worthy
it will change allegiance and work for
them
therefore in order for the one to come
into their possession in the first place
they will have needed to have proved
their worthiness what do you guys think
about this do you believe that there
lies the possibility of other items
being drawn from the sorting hat do you
have a theory of your own comment down
below if you enjoy the content don't
forget to like the video and subscribe
to the channel
until next time remember it does not do
to dwell on dreams and forget to live
you